les algériens sont devenus de vrais
montreux suisse à tous les vendredis sur
le coup de 14 heures après la prière ils
défilent par millions dans les rues du
pays
[Applaudissements]
ça fait dix-sept semaines que ça dure
nous ne sommes pas pour une un état
militaire nous ne sommes pas pour un
état religieux
nous sommes pour une démocratie qui
reconnaissent à tous à chacun le droit à
s'exprimer le droit à vivre dans cette
merveilleuse ville et dans ce
merveilleux pays boonen duflot call cet
homme est venu en bateau par la mer pour
déjouer les contrôles policiers sur la
route parce qu'il n'a il dit qu'à 40 ans
il ne peut toujours pas se marier parce
qu'il n'a pas un sou et pas de travail
c'est un grand événement pour moi le
média le quai des premiers mais nice qui
était arrogant qui est méprisé le peuple
aujourd'hui se trouve derrière les
barreaux dont la grande majorité des
manifestants les arrestations des
derniers jours celle des deux anciens
premiers ministres en plus des
principaux ancien conseiller du
président bouteflika ne sont pas
suffisantes
au contraire ils exigent le départ du
chef de l'armée du premier ministre
actuel et des ministres qui sont
toujours en poste
il ne faut pas donner une révolte au
milieu du chemin
parce que c'est pire que de ne que de
n'avoir pas commencé le peuple a dit si
dès maintenant
il lâchera jamais voilà l'affrontement
entre la population algérienne et le
pouvoir en place pour l instant faire
place à un début de négociation c'est en
tout cas ce que souhaitent de nombreux
militants et activistes sociaux
le système actuel est dans une impasse
totale et intégrale et la société civile
c'est de s'organiser pour justement
donner un prolongement politique à ce
mouvement populaire
les principaux syndicats et les
organismes populaire du pays ont
organisé une première conférence
nationale de la société civile à alger
beaucoup de monde beaucoup de tendances
beaucoup de discorde aussi le dit fier
aussi c'est à relever c'était de de
laisser cette image aux halles gêné aux
antilles elle qu'on peut être l'ensemble
c'est un message aussi à la famille
politique qui reste malheureusement
jusqu'à présent malgré qu'on est dans
une situation critique
je dirais très compliqué pour notre pays
restent dispersées ce que les algériens
souhaitent obtenir après le départ
éventuel des dirigeants politiques
restent encore vagues et imprécises
ce mouvement populaire n'a toujours pas
de leader ni de porte parole officiel la
crise politique algérienne risque donc
de durer encore longtemps
sylvain desjardins radio-canada alger